bonjour meriem genre alors expliquez
nous pourquoi une partie des
parlementaires péruvien voulait
destituer le président oui alors la
motion un visait la destitution du
président pour je cite un capacité
morale c'est une notion floue déjà
utilisée par le congrès en 2020 pour
destituer un précédent précédent
président marc cim 10 carats mais cette
fois la motion a recueilli seulement 46
voix en sa faveur et 76 contre
insuffisant pour donc ouvrir le débat au
parlement pour engager la procédure de
destitution en fait parmi les griefs
qu'il voulait de ce qu'ils voulaient
diriger dégagé pedro castillo et il y
avait des allégations de corruption
certains lui reprochaient des
interférences dans ce résumé dans des
promotions à l'intérieur de l'armée ou
encore des liens présumés entre les
membres de son entourage politique et le
groupe terroriste de gauche sentier
lumineux et ces derniers mois mérienne
les tensions se sont fait sentir au sein
même de la gauche et du camp
présidentiel qu'en est il oui en effet
pérou libre et le peuple propre parti
qui apporte et pedro cassis au pouvoir
un parti de gauche marxiste avait
envisagé un moment de soutenir la motion
visant à le destituer mais il s'est
rallié in extremis à quelques heures du
vote la veille donc du vote au président
même si il dit et continue à dire qu'il
n'est pas d'accord avec la politique que
pedro castillo entend mener
pour pedro castillo donc au delà de la
jem qui aurait représenté d'être lâché
par ceux là même qui ont l'ont porté au
pouvoir il ya aussi la problématique qui
est qui était qui se présentait devant
lui qui était que perron libre et
constitue une des princes il a plus
grande force au parlement
péruvien avec plus de trente sept
députés sur 130 c'est donc sans nul
doute un grand soulagement pour le
président il faut se souvenir que c'est
que mi-novembre à la direction du parti
perron libre elle n'avait pas hésité à
refuser son vote de confiance au cabinet
présidentiel estimant que le
gouvernement avait effectué je cite un
virage politique indéniable vers le
centre droit un mois plus tôt en effet
le 7 octobre pedro castro avait annoncé
la démission de son premier ministre
guide aux bd d'autant delà de la branche
très à gauche du parti ce qu'il n'avait
pas du tout plu à vladimir cerrone le
chef du parti péroniste mais est ce
qu'on peut dire que le président
castillo n'est pas vraiment à gauche non
on ne peut pas dire ça pedro castillo
défendre des projets politiques
indéniablement de gauche mais
visiblement pas suffisamment pour
certains il faut dire que déjà en
septembre il avait à washington nier que
son gouvernement était communiste
appelant les hommes d'affaires
américains à investir sans crainte dans
son pays mais tout en respectant les
règles dans ce pays très divisé
politiquement castillo cherche en fait
désespérément des soutiens consistant
consistant pour faire passer des
réformes politiques comme la
modification de la constitution qui
étrenne
constitution ultra libérale à travers
une assemblée constituante ainsi qu'une
réforme agraire s'en extraire
expropriations at il précisé merci
beaucoup meriem pour toutes ces
précisions meriem est l'arrivée notre
journaliste web ce matin